hey hey [ __ ] hey guys and we're gonna
play a crazy game called stole the boy
now many guys may have remembered this
from gamejolt before and it is now
released as kind of like a bigger title
it is just a demo for now but as you can
see it's very very polished so let's
take a look [ __ ] what is that [ __ ]
disgusting
it's like yelling ah no man withers and
the capture their [ __ ] was gonna touch
him
hahaha [ __ ] oh [ __ ] [ __ ] i hate when
this happens huh sleep apnea hillock his
eyes look at my nipples okay seamlessly
seamless Oh better check out this bong
that's talking and I can't raise that
[ __ ] okay let's get the bunny oh yeah we
can't touch that because if I [ __ ] is up
look at the bed alright let's take this
[ __ ] up everything we could [ __ ] grab
there's some good [ __ ] in here I like
this like a weirdo blow he has it was I
used condom or sewing okay let's get
back out of here let's get some real
stuff let's get some real stuff okay
okay let's check the door let's check
the door or at the closet actually yeah
family very [ __ ] in there okay let's
check this dresser oh yeah
oh let's get that candy bag is that
Oh does this guy have to get the candy
ok ok let's see you see you let's see oh
this thing's in the way oh my god that
is tragic ok ok oh yeah yeah yeah I got
I got it what is that tick oh here we
have that um let's just let's just check
out what's going on here oh [ __ ] me oh
what is that oh I can't get that again
ok so let's put uh yes very scary very
scary he likes bugs
no he does not like that okay I'll offer
him the tick offer him uh Dean last
chance in here oh I [ __ ] them up say
God I mean we need like another 10 we
have to give him three things okay I got
you I got you okay um that's adorable
yes I don't know it's up there okay so
we need this dude let's go far to the
right you can do there nothing's there
all right let's check this out because
really there's nothing in here so far
Oh can't reach a cane trees dent all
right me like a stick or something god I
hate know this happens all right stick
stick stick stick stick maybe we'll I
light up writer Wow amazing okay ah ah
scary scary what may of the shock
remember twenties I made that okay ready
are you get over the get over there yeah
yeah
I can only get her I'm again yeah I'm
again look at him yeah [ __ ] him up yeah
yeah yeah I got your sorry ass right
here ah yes sucker how you like that I
got you your candy dee licious in you
okay I need a stick where the heck out
the sticks okay well let me go in there
anymore it won't let me go in here
anymore what happened do it what is this
Oh room for under here where the [ __ ]
with room
okay this guide is only
getting a room oh that's right here okay
well though creepy [ __ ] poster right
here
yeah good oh yeah okay
senior I I got your the pesos you demand
it and here's my use condo well alright
how's weird yes get in there get in
there
[ __ ] I [ __ ] knew it [ __ ] knew it
oh [ __ ] lambs we don't clean out your
fleshlight
yeah what is that look fast fast fast
demo all right guess that's it
um but if we had to guess what the game
would be like we have Bo boy here we
have this weird [ __ ] thing and we
have Mr rabbit over here that's just
tripping on balls and we got his father
which is like a bomb or something so
that's it see you later yow